von der achten in die zehnte klasse
einfach mal von 11 auf 624 4 stunden
etwas glaubt und jetzt willkommen bei
einem neuen video ja leute ich hoffe
natürlich euch geht's gut ich glaube das
habe ich jetzt auch schon bestimmt 200
mal so gesagt gegen mich die kamera noch
ein bisschen zu weit unten so meine
haare seiten schon wieder so lange
deswegen muss ich dir jetzt nach hinten
machen aber sieht ja auch in tokios
häufig bedeute bevor wir heute anfangen
muss ich erst mal sagen alter wirklich
richtig richtig großes dankeschön hat
mich sehr gefreut das letzte video zu
dem thema zeugnisse ist ja extrem gut
bei euch angekommen
ich glaube es hat mittlerweile fast
eineinhalb millionen klicks also
wirklich absoluter rekord für mich und
das war glaube ich auch schon so mein
drittes oder viertes video zu dem thema
ich habe euch allerdings auf dem kanal
gefragt ja soll ich noch ein video dazu
machen oder nicht und die abstimmung sei
also aus und haben gesagt ja erreicht so
langsam aber die mehrzahl hat gesagt er
alex bitte mach noch ein video dazu
unter dem ich das video hochgeladen habe
habe ich wirklich ungelogen bestimmt
über 1000 oder 2000 zeigt dass sie
irgendwo zugeschickt bekommen von
irgendwem von euch deswegen war die
auswahl ist umso schwerer aber ich hab
mir logischerweise wir ein paar
rausgesucht die schauen wir uns heute
zusammen an das recht wieder was
witziges dabei oder vor allem auch was
interessant ist und ich würde sagen
let's go bei 10.000 likes diesmal gibt
es noch eine folge davon liegt also an
euch du das erste zeugnis kommt von
einer etwas jüngere zuschauerinnen und
weiß dass die lina dina geht in die 15
da war ich auch mal drin stimmt gar
nicht war eine fünffach so genau das ist
natürlich auch das aktuelle schuljahr es
gab er jetzt glaube ich in den meisten
bundesländern wenn nicht schon in allen
wieder zeugnisse vielleicht lag es auch
daran dass nicht so viele zugeschickt
bekommen habe auf jeden fall geht lena
auf eine realschule und der grund warum
ich dieses zeug das jetzt mit
reingenommen haben
das hat mich einfach sehr irritiert weil
ich habe noch nie davon gehört dass auch
im zeugnis steht sogar drei bis vier das
machen wir mal so auf die lina so ein
bio das ist so irgendwas zwischen zwei
und fünf kannst du ja an sich nicht viel
mit anfangen weil ich finde eigentlich
immer gut wenn man wirklich einfach auf
den punkt gesagt bekommen das ist eine
note was soll das denn hier 3 bis 4 2
bis 3
deutsch ist hier eigentlich drei monate
4 - das macht gar keinen sinn dieses
zeugnis also ich versteh ich wirklich
nicht so ganz aber sicher gar nicht so
schlecht aus
schön am ball bleiben linie sonst wird
aus der 4 - in mathe auf schnell meine
das kann man unterschätzt okay mein
letztes video das hieß ja ich glaube 289
fehlstunden ich reagiere auf eure
zeugnisse und in den kommentaren auch
wirklich sehr sehr viele geschrieben hat
289 ist gar nicht so viel ich hatte
schon 500 oder so habe ich an sich
erstmal gar nicht so gelaufen ich mein
500 wirklich dann war es ja nie da
man braucht ja auch kein zeugnis kriegen
also beweisen sind dann natürlich immer
gut
und dann habe ich jetzt gerade dieses
zeugnis gefunden wir haben hier der name
ist zensiert das ist wahrscheinlich auch
besser so hoch zahl der versäumten
unterrichtsstunden 624 davon nicht
gerechtfertigt okay das ist dann
wahrscheinlich krankheitsbedingt und das
tut wir dann natürlich immer sehr leid
nur was man wirklich sagen muss kann man
die person war wirklich nur 100 stunden
maximal da und drücken ist der oder die
in deutsch auf eine drei in
betriebssysteme 1 und die anderen beiden
sachen die noch bewertet wurden die vier
also das ist finde ich schon eine
bemerkenswerte leistung wenn man halt
wirklich 624 fehlstunden hat ich glaube
bei uns der rekord in der stufe lag 250
oder so und das war schon echt viel
ach nee am ende hatten wir auch eine die
kam echt nicht mehr ich weiß es gar
nicht mehr also auf jeden fall ich hoffe
du wirst schnell wieder fit was auch
immer du hast und dann wird das schon
wieder was schüler der ist ein schüler
der cd stufe aber auf jeden fall der
neue rekord an versorgte
unterrichtsstunden sowie machen weiter
mit dem nächsten zeugnis das bezieht
sich auf die 8a und hier muss ich auch
sagen sonst zeugnis habe ich noch nie
gesehen da gibt keine noten da gibt es
anscheinend auch nur fünf fächer und da
wird es dann in prozent angegeben hatte
bist du suchen 35 prozent deutsch 80
prozent technik machen wir 45 prozent
ist an sich finde ich auch eine coole
sache vor allem das hört sich dann gar
nicht alles direkt so hart an
ich meine wir nur auf dem zeugnis stehen
hast mangel habt das ist ja sofort oder
denkst du scheiße war das schlecht wenn
da was schiffen zehn prozent 19 prozent
hört sich doch ganz nah dann ich weiß
nicht ob ihr versteht was ich meine
aber ich habe es mal also ich finde ich
auf jeden fall eine gute
alternativlösung neben diesem harten
notensystem vor allem vielleicht für
schüler die generell nicht so gut sind
in der schule ein
so ein bisschen motivation dahinter zu
übrigen jahr noch weiter und so wird das
nächste wird mir glaube ich von
irgendein mädchen geschickt und sie hat
dazu geschrieben ich konnte meiner mama
wenigstens sagen dass ich dem sport 1 1
haben allerdings muss ich sagen rallye
vier deutsch vier englisch 34 erdkunde
viel mathe 5 ohne witz das ist ja
wirklich so ne die meisten firmen gibt
es einfach in mathe ich glaube so eine
studie aufgestellt werden wo gibt es die
meisten fünften oder was steht bei den
meisten schülern in mathe auf dem
zeugnis wird dann mangelhaft rauskommen
jedes zweite zeugnis dass ich bekomme
mathe chemie vier bio vier kunst 4 und
sport1 also ein sportler 1 ist ja immer
was cooles vielleicht solltest du die
fünf in mathe weg bekommen dann kommst
du wenigstens durch glaube ich nicht
ausreichende leistung können die
versetzung gefährdet
sie ist und jetzt kommen wir zum
absoluten burger zeugnis dass ich bis
heute nicht verstehen
gut man erst mal unten hin versäumnisse
57 tage davon unentschuldigt 45 tage man
muss jetzt aber erst mal sagen das sind
halb ja ungefähr aus ich will jetzt mal
schätzen 120 schultagen besteht also die
person war auf jeden fall mehr als die
hälfte da hat dann allerdings in
komplett ein fächern nicht feststellbar
eine leistungsfeststellung in sämtlichen
fächern konnte aufgrund der hohen
fehlzeiten nicht stattfinden
auch weil du jetzt 45 tage davon
unentschuldigt warst gehe ich jetzt mal
davon aus dass du nicht krank war es
also ich will natürlich ist auch nichts
falsches sagen kann natürlich immer sein
falls ja tut es mir leid und ich nehme
alles zurück was ich jetzt sage aber die
person eben mit einem 624 fehlstunden
die war ja noch weniger da als duo
erwartet trotzdem jeden wo meine note
jedoch wenigstens zu sportlern ich meine
das kann auch manchmal ganz cool sollen
also wir haben jetzt wirklich das
schlechteste zeugnis das ich jemals
hatte also es gab wirklich niemand
anderen der mit dem service zugeschickt
hat wo einfach komplett überall nicht
bewertbar stand okay das war ich auch
noch mit rein nehmen und zwar haben wir
hier ein
zwischenzeugnis ich nur mal damit ihr
sowas auch mal seht das zeugnis von der
lieben melodie wenn du die ich glaube
wir hatten auch in unserem französisch
gut so eine melodie de melody eigentlich
was erstmal sagen richtig cooler name
das hört sich echt so groß wie melodie
reimt sich sogar also für die die keinen
französisch können das heißt hallo ich
bin melodie ok säure egal
ja wir haben hier halt punkte glaube ich
in frankreich werden anscheinend punkte
verteilt ich kann jetzt so gut wie gar
nichts davon analysieren so sieht ein
französisches zeugnis aus irgendwie voll
kompliziert oder ok ich wollte euch das
noch mal zeigen wir kommen jetzt
allerdings zu einer echt interessanten
story finde ich die ich auch auf jeden
fall jetzt in dem video mal ansprechen
wollte und zwar hat wie die person eine
echt lange mehr geschick mit auch vier
oder drei zeugnissen von ihm er hat dazu
geschrieben bitte nenne mich im video
lukas würde gerne bleiben also lukas was
geht ich lese ich das jetzt einfach mal
vor heute gut zu hören
ich weiß nicht wo ich anfangen soll ich
fange mal so in der achten schulstufe
merkte ich dass sich jungs anziehen
finde mache mir aber noch keine sorgen
da ich dachte es sei nur die pubertät da
war mein zeugnis doch top siehe anhang
danach ging ich in eine höhere schule wo
das theater hand wenn ich stand auf
einem schulkollegen und kann damit nicht
klar da ich mich so schimpft dann wurde
dann krank und wurde für das komplette
zweite halbjahr freigestellt mir wurde
es dann zu viel und ich wechselte in die
fachschule die erste klasse schaffte ich
nur gegen ende fing das problem wieder
da ich meine gefühle für jungs
unterdrückte anfang ist der zweiten
klasse zehnten schulstufe wurde alles
schlimmer
ich wurde stark depressiv und suizid
gefährdet bis ich in ein krankenhaus
musste hatte somit 600 fehlt stunden im
ersten jahr alter auf 600 hast seite hat
ja konnte ich die schule auch nicht
besuchen habe mich dann von der schule
abgemeldet da ich angst vor mobbing
haben also auf jeden fall echt klasse
story kann ich jetzt eigentlich nicht so
viel zu sagen kenne ich mich überhaupt
nicht aus mit dem thema beim in der
stufe gab es jetzt nicht irgendwie
sondern extremfall sage ich jetzt mal
irgendwie der halt so stark auffällig
was sowas betrifft war oder so aber ist
ja klar ich meinen lukas ist denke ich
mal nicht ganz alleine vielleicht ist ja
der ein oder andere von euch die das
video werkschau in einer ähnlichen
situation wir schauen uns jetzt
allerdings erstmal die zeugnisse von
lukas an und zwar achte schulstufe
komplett alles sehr gut aussah lebende
fremdsprachen gut hammer gutes zeugnis
ist auch schon achte klasse gewesen also
dass es nicht mehr so leicht und dann
jetzt hier schon in der zehnten klasse
meine ich oder was ist es englisch nicht
bewertbar naturwissenschaften nicht
bewertbar systemtechnik für angewandte
mathematik schon wieder fünf schon mehr
jemand der eine fünf in mathe aber
natürlich jetzt ausgründung in diesem
fall computer beamer auch mit 4 software
entwicklung nicht bestanden
medientechnik nicht bestanden ist dann
schon deutlich abgerutscht wenn diese
beiden zeugnisse miteinander vergleicht
ist ja voll heftig und das innerhalb
eines jahres ok und jetzt muss ich dazu
sagen ich hab das voll durcheinander
geworfen weil ich das irgendwann mal
gespeichert hatte ich dachte das wäre
ein einzel zeugnis von irgendjemand
anderem das zeug das habt ihr eben schon
mal gesehen mit den 624 fehlstunden also
das gehört dann im luca das habe ich
dann leider ebenfalls zu gehabt in
deiner sorry aber ich hätte ich ganz so
schlimm also wenn man hier seht dann
halt zehnte klasse ich glaube das war
jetzt der verlauf von der achten in die
zehnte klasse einfach mal von 1,1 auf
624 4 stunden also leute das ist
vielleicht ein sehr gutes beispiel dafür
dass wenn jemand bei euch aus der stufe
nicht so besonders gut in der schule
oder oft fehlt das muss nicht immer
heißen auch die person schwänzt oder die
person hat keine lust oder können hat
auch gründen dahinter seien deswegen
nicht immer sofort taucht da so ist das
ja meistens in der schule der lukas hat
in der mail geschrieben ich will das
jetzt wenigstens ganz vorlesen mein tipp
an alle die so ähnlich fühlen wie ich
redet mit jemanden der mir vertraut
unterdrückt bitte nichts an den fehler
habe ich gemacht kannst den text gerne
verbessern aber bitte mir vorher sein
damit ich gegebenenfalls bei falschem
inhalt ihr bescheid geben könnt also
habe ich noch nicht verbessert okay das
waren wirklich wieder eine menge
interessante zeugnisse lustige zeugnisse
nicht so lustig zeigt ist ich hoffe dass
wieder deutlich gefallen wie gesagt
10.000 chips sachen park wollten wir
gern bei installieren oder snapshot und
wir sind uns wahrscheinlich morgen
wieder hast du vielleicht noch ganz kurz
zu dem gewinnspiel
es steht jetzt schon eigentlich bin auch
fest für das iphone und die playstation
dort ist auch schon ein freund
kontaktierte die personen die gewonnen
hat weiß ich jetzt allerdings noch nicht
morgen fahre ich los und überreichten
das iphone und das video kommt dazu dann
auch also macht euch keine gedanken
darüber dass es nicht aufgelöst wird
ich bin sehr gespannt und ich freue mich
morgen den gewinnern das iphone
übergeben zu können und ja wir sehen uns
hat rein